so we're here with four-time US Women's
Champion on as a Tomsky Anna welcome you
always seem to have good results when
you travel to the States
yeah thank you tell us about your
preparations for the tournament I don't
know actually it's very difficult to say
if I mean I will tell progress the first
a second game I will know for sure if
and good shape or not is it not
necessary to have a big ego to be
successful in just oh I don't know then
if you have big area you have a lot of
expectations from yourself so it's a lot
of pressure
probably this why don't you have it I
know last year's US Women's Chess
Championship you had to play something
like 19 games or something yeah how long
did it take to recover from last year's
event I don't know if furnace took a lot
of months and I remember I was watching
my husband playing in Rohtak up for
World Cup Berchem our championship in
2006 and I saw other guys plain ty
breaks and I feel like so like I'm so
happy it's not me playing this tiebreaks
I was extremely exhausted and tightened
every member of the US Women's Chess
Championship last year is playing again
this year except for two new females
what do you know about your new
competition and who played them before I
know only Victorian year I know her
because first of all she's from Latvia
and my husband is also from Latvia I met
her before and I don't know about young
Ilona cuts if she got invited to the
sternum
which means she's strong rival tell us
why you think women's only a tournament
should exist okay first of all if you
consider like historical usually people
can compare chess with war and war used
to be a man's privilege
okay nowadays of course women also goes
to army and but historically women now
didn't work didn't go to war so I think
it's like man had huge advantage before
more men played chess than women and of
course there is a big gap between men
and women chess but it's getting narrow
wanna always play well in st. Louis so
we look forward to another fortnight of
uncompromising chess yeah thank you
thanks very much